vannes s'est classé deux anciens
camarades de collège se retrouve des
années plus tard et après avoir essayé
de se persuader mutuellement qu'ils ont
réussi finissent par reconnaître que
leurs femmes ne sont pas très amusante
et que leur fraud and autrefois leur
manque
ils font des projets d'avenir bon ça
c'est la situation alors pour compliquer
l'astuce et pour compliquer la tâche de
nos deux beaux acteurs se sont massés
compliqué qui seront en l'occurrence
roger carel des théâtres parisiens et
jean marc thibault de nos meilleurs
cafés concerts oui pour compliquer la
tâche 10h cette situation doit être
content va se clore par une phrase
obligatoire à digne c'est à dire qu'à
partir du coup de clochettes
retentissant nos camarades auront à dire
en situation et le premier enfin le
premier le premier qui l'a dit ray aura
gagné ils auront à dire j'aime les
bananes parce qu'après 2 je crois que
c'est quand même une tranche de vie
c'est une chose qui se dit dans la vie
où l'état tous les jours alors allez-y
mais petit bonhomme haut comme calaisis
à l'espace gemme les bananes parce
cappadoce de fizi non
plusieurs sorties arts études c'est la
dernière fois que tu fais cette émission
on voulait pour la reprendre déjà j'y
vais non morisod non on aura un bon
brasier nous donnons un beau chat mienne
non
paré là on s'est fendu d'un coup d'essai
écoute je cours après les 50 années cas
quand j'ai quitté protège oui c'est un
film de terence sa manche et les frères
à la vraie on avait là des carpentier
c'est ça oui oh bah oui après y'a pas le
collège j'ai voulu faire les dames n'ont
fait bien les envies d'artois motivée
elle est préparée conservatoire mais
c'est vrai qu'ils chantaient 681 chanter
à la chapelle je suis bien d'accord
qu'on le p2p recenseur est mort assurée
d'y bâtir près tout ce que j'ai fait
tout ça ça m'a bien lancé à bordeaux
oui mais je pouvais avec un l et es pas
de calais enfin maintenant je fais
encore des photos mais oui c'est plus
pareil fait des photos pour la publicité
des charcuteries
bah oui moi aussi j'ai pu épouser une
esthéticienne à bâiller en effet si elle
a été non parce qu'on a on a observé
deux tu vois je te disais c'est quoi
elle savait très bas a joué pour les
riches tout ça et ça avait on cherche
dans les pas de sa part qu'elle m'en
fais la mienne
oui enfin on la voit au fond se marrait
bien on la voit moi ça va je suis dans
l'industrie lourde et enfin tu fais quoi
exactement
faut savoir aussi un me disait sympa
parce que je vois je prends de
l'exercice toute la nuit c'est une
grande usine doit il a oublié bas toute
la nuit je marche dans cette usine
je suis la nuit là il est ouvert la nuit
basterds je fus veilleur de nuit
ah ben oui merci pour ce patient simple
comment afficher parce que moi je suis
beaucoup de provinces maintenant des
heures tu sais amérique tout ça pour
monter ce jour à paris jusqu'à liqueurs
à d'ailleurs signalé coeur puisque la
politique et la ligue du faucon noir on
va tous les rois de la sorte nous rire
de tout si on rentre et je devais
j'allais là tu connais pas
j'allais chercher la une une ruée sur le
jeu je trouve pas trouvé dans le plan
des revenus attendus
james libanais c'est une je pense plus à
la cantine
pourquoi n'y a jamais de bananes et si
jamais banal parce qu'à part de dons
mais non moi j'aime son ex